تصور ان تحصل على فرصه للحديث مع احبائك
الراحلين سنوات تشارك معهم نجاحاتك
المهنيه حفله تخرجك زواجك وتتلقى منهم
رضوضا في اللحظه وكانها مكالمه فيديو هذا
ما تقدمه ديبران اي اي وهي شركه كوريه
جنوبيه للذكاء الاصطناعي تستخدم التعلم
الالي لمعالجه الصور ومقاطع الافراد
المتوفين لانشاء توام رقمي من الشخص
الراحل يمكنه التفاعل مع الاحياء يجيب على
اسئلتهم ويشارك معهم ذكريات الماضي الشروط
تصوير مقابله مسبقه مع الشخص الراغب في
تطوير نسخه الافتراضيه لها لمده سبع ساعات
يقوم اذا كان اصطناعي بالتعرف على
سلوكياته وانطباعاته اجعل المحادثات
طبيعيه بعد وفاته تطوير النسخه الافتراضيه
يتراوح بين اثني عشره واربعه وعشرين الف
دولار لكن في كل مره ترغب فيها التحدث مع
هذه النسخه الافتراضيه سيكون عليك ان تدفع
1,000 و200$
طيب تقنيه جديده اليوم نتحدث يا عبد الله
للحديث او المحادثه مع الموتى من خلال
محادثات او مكالمات افتراضيه نتحدث عن
اليه عملها بالاول هذه التقنيه
في حياتنا بتطلع في مشاريع مختلفه
واستخدامات مختلفه الشيء اللي قاعد يشوفه
حاليا جدا بسيط من استخدامات الذكاء
الاصطناعي من قدره الذكاء الاصطناعي
واستخدامه للتقنيه المختلفه اللي موجوده
فلذلك شيء مثل هذا القبيله وشيء جدا همم
لكنه همم لازم نعرف انه بامكان ايضا اذا
كان الصناعي تزيد الصوت الفيديو وغيرها من
استخدامات الخطيره الثانيه فلذلك زي ما
نحن فوائد محاسن ايضا راح يكون لها مشاكل
لكن
محاسن الذكاء الاصطناعي فوائده في
المستقبل المستخدمين اكبر من الشيء اللي
احنا ممكن استخدامات ايش الفرق
اكبر من احنا ممكن نعرف بين انه واحد يسجل
فيديو قبل مماته وبين هذه التقنيه هل
سيظهر الشخص افتراديا كانه موجود
شغلات كثيره ممكن احنا نستفيد منها الامر
اللي ذكر اليوم هو امر جدا بسيط وسهل جدا
همم يعني ما هو شيء معقد بشكل جدا كبير من
استخدامات الذكاء الاصطناعي هو توفير
البيئه افتراضيه وعمل همم استخدامات معينه
وبعدها
تقليد الصوت لازم نعرف ان همم هذه مثلا
شيء مدفوع لكن يجب ان تعرفونه مايكروسوفت
على سبي بتاع ال- اا قاعد تطور خدمه خلال
سبع ثواني قادر النظام الذكاء الاصطناعي
من تقليد صوتك ما يحتاج فيديو لمده سبع
ساعات علشان يقلدون نبرد صوتك او يوصلون
لدرجه الصوت حقتك فالموضوع بعيد الطور جدا
سريع يعني يقدم خدمات اكثر يا عبد الله في
هذه التقنيه كثيره
الوجه يعني الشخص يكون قدامك يحكي كانه هو
فعلا الشخص اللي كان عليه
تقريبا
اللي كانت همم تمشي في تزيين في الاصوات
مقاطع فيديو تقريبا هم يستخدم قريب منها
لذلك الموضوع ترى ابعد استخدامات ابعد عن
المدى الطويل وخدمات كثيره ممكن تسويه
احد يشتريات الان عندها مشروع انت مثلا لو
تكلم باللغه العربيه هذه اللقاء مثلا كان
في اللغه العربيه بامكان نفس الشركه عن
طريق الذكاء الاصطناعي تغيير اللغه الى
اكثر من 17 لغه تعابير الوجه نفس كل شيء
همم وتقدم لك خبر او المقابله 19 لغه
مختلفه كانك انت انك انت قاعد تتكلم فيها